[Music]
good evening and welcome to the final
long now seminar of the decade here at
SF jazz my name is Nicholas Paul brazo
it's and I'm the director of development
here at the long now foundation and I'd
like to begin tonight by thanking all of
you out there who support this series
and who support our foundation with your
regular long noun membership especially
I'd like to thank all of you out there
who are able to upgrade your membership
this year earlier when we were asking
for people to go from eight dollars a
month to twelve dollars a month that
show of support means the world to us
and it actually makes a huge difference
especially when you aggregate it all
together if you take all of your
memberships together it actually makes
up a significant fraction of our general
operating budget every single year and
the other significant fraction that
general operating budget arrives at the
end of every year in November in
December during the giving season as
part of our annual fundraising campaign
we're a lot of people who support this
work and believe in this mission right
you know do a special one-time
tax-deductible gifts to the long now
foundation to support our work for
another year and there's lots of
different ways to plug in we're always
looking for sponsors of the seminar
series
there's the bottles at the interval
which can be donated for we also looking
for sponsors for the bookshelves at the
interval and I still have a few equation
of time cams if you want to own a piece
of the clock as well so we'd ask that if
you can this year please consider
including us in your philanthropic plans
it would mean the world to us and please
don't forget to ask your employer about
gift matching opportunities a lot of
employers as you probably know will
match your donations to long now one two
one two two one and I even know some
companies that will do three to one or
more and with on that note and without
any further ado I'll leave you with
tonight's inspirational long short with
audio from Neil Gaiman's from our 2015
long now seminar thank you enjoy the
show
along now and the clock of the long now
is about planning for the long term and
thinking in the long term in a world in
which people appear to be thinking in
the shorter and shorter term Tom Sabo
concluded you couldn't actually create a
story that would last 10,000 years you
could only create a story that would
last for three generations for ourselves
for our children for their children but
we can do
I think it's try and create stories but
it interesting enough
and our grandchildren might want to tell
those stories to their grandchildren
because that's the purpose of Storace
its what therefore make life worth
living
and sometimes they keep us alive
[Music]
thank you neil gaiman hi I'm Stuart
brand from the long now foundation the
speaker tonight is says usual talking in
the sort of usual 10,000 year frame he
focuses especially in the last 200 years
she says that starting about 1800 number
trends got going there surprisingly good
news and that are continuing to
accelerate and have impact but it's more
than the 200 year now he's actually a
210 year now because he has made some
long bets 10-year long bets about the
u.s. mostly about the US economy 14 bets
that he is putting up a hundred thousand
dollars of his own money to back these
bets and if you see things in tonight's
talk that seem like that can't be true
and it certainly can't play out the way
this guy thinks it will think about what
you'd like to bet with him on long says
about that so money where his mouth is
Andrew McAfee
Stewart thanks so much I think like a
number of people here I first came
across Stuart brand and his work from
the Whole Earth Catalog my mom actually
had some early issues of it and I
remember keenly being this extremely
socially awkward preteen in Indiana
I remember that really really really
cleanly but but coming across this and
having some kind of periscope or portal
to a completely different world in a
completely different way of thinking
that I became enamored of and I've been
carrying with me I think I first met
Stuart about ten years ago at a
conference and I honestly sat by myself
in the corner trying to work up the
courage to go talk to him
because III was fanboying him that hard
and I went up and we had the most
stilted awful conversation because I had
stars in my eyes whose complete movie
star moment I think I actually asked him
if he did his own stunts it was that it
was that level of horrible but things
have improved a little bit since then
and I'm thrilled this is kind of like
the the geek equivalent of getting asked
to give a recital at Carnegie Hall being
asked to come and give a long now
seminar it's just it really as a dream
come true so Stuart thank you thank you
all for coming out
whether or not we end on a high note
tonight we're gonna start on a low note
I want to give kind of a very quick
guided tour or litany of some of the
very big problems that we're confronting
right now and I wish I could say it was
hard work to come up with this litany it
wasn't right you fire up your browser
and immediately you start hearing how
many years we have left to reverse this
trend of global warming where we are
cooking the planet and the downside
risks the list of really bad things that
could happen appears to be actually
unlimited that's how bad it can be a
number of people think that we might be
at the beginning some signs are showing
up that we might be at the beginning of
one of the rare but really bad news mass
extinction events in the world's history
could be driving many of our fellow
creatures out of existence and pollution
is literally everywhere on our planet by
now the source of all these problems is
obvious to everybody here unfortunately
it's us we are the driver of these
things that's happening and in
particular this this mania that we seem
to have form or for growth for higher
populations for higher levels of
economic activity for economic growth
year after year we've built this
relentless voracious engine of more and
a lot of people think that is the
fundamental problem and maybe one that
doesn't have a lot of obvious solutions
and what I want to do is dive in on this
approach this question of can we keep
doing this growth thing by looking at
our history of realizing articulating
and confronting very very big problems
that we faced in the past and to
introduce our first big problem let's
have a pop quiz does anyone recognize
this famous pessimist shout it out if
you know it yeah so this is our friend
the Reverend Thomas Malthus whose name
has given us an adjective Malthusian
that I at least use as an insult toward
other people took a note that they're
being too gloomy and too pessimistic
because Malthus published an essay right
at the end of the 18th century where he
said look gang we got a problem most of
us are going to starve no matter what we
do about it
and malthus's point was look you can do
the math it's pretty simple the size of
human communities tends to grow
exponentially two four eight sixteen
Malthus said our ability to take
resources from the earth to feed
ourselves only grows linearly two three
four five those two lines are going to
cross at some point and when they do
really unpleasant corrective mechanisms
kick in like starvation deprivation
privation drives down the size of the
human community so he said if you think
about population and prosperity as these
two axes we would like to live here but
we can't that's actually not how it
works and in the essay he was really
clear that were essentially doomed to
oscillate between these two states
between a state where there aren't very
many of us who are comparatively
well-off and then we start having more
kids because things are good we outstrip
the our ability to take food and other
resources from the land and these cruel
corrective mechanisms kick back in and
we go back down the pendulum now a lot
of us carry around the notion that
Malthus was actually a pretty lousy
forecaster and we're gonna sharpen that
intuition one of the things I learned
when I was researching more from less he
was a weirdly good historian and we say
this because thanks to some wonderful
work by economic historians like Gregory
Clark we now have a pretty good glimpse
about what happened over hundreds of
years in decent sized communities the
English economy is one that we have good
data on going back hundreds of years
about our relationship on these two axes
of population and prosperity so I want
to walk you through a few hundred years
of the situation in England leading up
to the publication of malthus's essay so
here's what the 1200s
like in England here the 1300s here are
the 1400s 1500s 1600s things got a
little bit better in the 1700s because
our agricultural practices improved but
look at that line for the 1700s
throughout that century the average
Britain was worse off than they were in
the year 1200 we really were living in
this world that Malthus described but
doesn't feel like we live there anymore
at least to the same extent and a very
short explanation for what changed what
happened is I think this gentleman pop
quiz number two if you had to name the
father of the Industrial Revolution who
would that be
so here's James Watt and the reason
James Watts name is famous is that he
tinkered enough to build an economically
efficient steam engine and for the first
time allowed us human beings to tap into
the crazy amounts of energy stored in
the world's fossil fuels and the world
changed as a result of Watts inventions
and the other technologies and
institutions of the Industrial
Revolution
we're probably tired of hearing the
Industrial Revolution changed everything
we still underestimate it's it's I think
it's very hard to overstate how big a
deal this transition was and how much
the world changed as a result I want to
show how big a deal it was by continuing
to draw exactly that same graph so here
we are back at population and prosperity
and we're gonna look at a couple more
centuries worth of data to do that
though we have to take all the data that
we've already looked at and shrink it
down into that corner of the graph
because this is what the 1800s look like
in England and this is what the 1900s
look like we finally get to that
quadrant of the graph where we don't
face that oscillation that trade-off
between high prosperity and high
population the trajectory of this
country anyway
changes and assumes a shape that we have
never ever seen before as far back as we
can look and another way to say what's
going on is that when there are more and
more English people and their average
prosperity is going up this is the same
thing as saying that GDP is growing like
we've never ever seen before
so GDP is just a measure of how much
total stuff the economy produces and it
was really boring for hundreds of years
and then that graph completely changed
shape after the Industrial Revolution
this is not just an English story if you
look at the entire world they started
from a lower place but then their
prosperity throughout the globe has
increased even more quickly around the
world GDP is about 100 times higher than
it was in 1800 so we don't worry so much
about these Malthusian dilemmas in fact
we can actually look at the exact
phenomenon Malthus was interested in
these deprivation induced famines and
see how they have changed over time
there's fantastic data on famine deaths
by decade this is some morbid stuff to
look at but you can go grab data on
famine deaths by decade going back about
a hundred and fifty years and you notice
they're tailing off in recent decades
this is a great phenomenon this is kind
of surprising because this is what
happened to the world's population over
that exact same time as our population
is really increased more quickly than
ever before
famine deaths are actually going down
instead of going up and it's even more
impressive to me if we gray out the
famines that are due to the unbelievably
bad economic mistake of collectivizing
of putting all your people and
collective farms and revving a centrally
planned economy that is a really great
way to generate dire famines if we gray
those out and look at the famines
generated by the rest of the world you
just see a drop off like we've never
seen before so Malthus was a weirdly
good amateur historian a terribly bad
forecaster because the problem that he
identified we simply can't feed anybody
that was overturned by the Industrial
Revolution
and worries about mass famines have just
they've just faded away as we've moved
deeper and deeper into the industrial
era and as we had about a more than 150
years worth of experience in this era we
started to get alarmed about another
pretty dire problem and in fact in a
sense the opposite of the Malthus
problem the second problem that we
started to worry about a lot was we were
just gonna exhaust the bounty of the
earth Malthus said we can't possibly
scratch enough of a living from the
earth this is the opposite this is we're
gonna take everything I take all the
resources all the minerals all the
productive capacity of the earth as we
continue to increase the size of our
populations the size of our economies
our voracious appetites are going to
deplete this planet that we all live on
we started to hear this a lot around the
time of the first Earth Day in 1970 I am
pretty sure I haven't asked Stewart
directly I am pretty sure he was
somewhere on the scene of one of these
Earth Day gatherings that happened all
across the country and you can look at
the data that was available around the
time of Earth Day and you might come to
the same conclusion so here again this
is the American economy we're going to
switch over to America because the
evidence is actually much much better
and goes back pretty far here here's 170
years almost the entire industrial era
of the American economy coming up to the
Year 1970 coming up to the first Earth
Day this is the growth of the economy we
might like that this is how much energy
we needed to generate that economy year
after year these true lines go up
completely in lockstep this is an
extraordinarily tight relationship to
the point that we actually had a
shorthand and if you looked at the total
amount of energy consumed in an economy
you would have a really good guess of
how advanced that economy was there's a
lot of research that treated these two
as synonyms for each other and it wasn't
just energy it wasn't just fossil fuels
if you look we're gonna homed in on the
20th century now and if you look at our
consumption year after year of some
other pretty important resources
come to the same conclusion this is what
our total use year after year of some
important metals was of the of the main
fertilizers that we use and you start to
look at it and say hey I think we have a
problem we live on a finite planet and
these exponential curves don't show any
sign of running out of steam those gray
lines can't really keep doing what
they're doing indefinitely and there was
this wonderful series of relatively
gloomy books written right around the
time of the first Earth Day I am
actually not sure that last title needs
the exclamation point I think we get it
but this was the first round of really
deep concern about this trajectory that
we were on with our population and our
economic growth and you can go back and
you can find people saying very similar
things to what we're hearing today that
gang this can't continue we have to stop
this we are making an ongoing very very
serious mistake
the solution is kind of unpleasant the
solution is that we have to walk away
from growth itself and this is when you
started to hear about the D growth
movement nicely articulated here says
look the leveling off our consumption is
not enough flat lining is actually not
enough we have to make that green line
that line of gdp start going down over
time if we want those grey lines of
total resource use to ought to actually
also go down and a slogan that you
started to hear was that the only
sustainable growth for us for our
societies and for our planet was d
growth I want to make one thing as clear
as I possibly can we did not do this
we Americans look around we Americans
have not voluntarily renounced affluence
grow growth prosperity having a better
standard of living year after year we
have not all masks just kind of turned
into a nation of buddhist monks and
renounced all of that we Americans we
like our prosperity we like our where
like our affluence we actually we like
our stuff I love this image so much this
kind of post-war dream of what American
prosperity looked like there was a lot
of stuff there and to be quantitative
about it here is the American economy up
till about 1970 here's what's been
happening in the years since 1970 that
exponential growth just keeps going
maybe it slowed down a little bit from
the gogo post-war years but our economy
is more than two and a half times as big
as it was during the time of Earth Day
the world's economy once again has
started from a lower place but growing
even more quickly the world's economy is
about three and a half times as big as
it was in 1970 so you know you see that
and you start to get concerned that
these Earth Day folk were onto something
here I want to talk about two really
surprising things that I learned when I
was researching the book having to do
with those grey lines with our use of
resources and the first is the
relationship between that growth that we
just looked at and scarcity versus
abundance versus affordability of the
physical building blocks of the
resources that we use to construct an
economy and to be clear scarcity and
affordability are essentially opposites
here as things become more scarce they
become more expensive they become less
affordable in fact just the threat that
a resource might become scarce is enough
to send the prices through the roof we
see this with every episode of
instability in the Middle East oil
prices take a nice sharp bump upward
because we anticipate the wells haven't
been shut off yet but we anticipate that
oil and other hydrocarbons are going to
become scarce the price effect is
immediate here so a really important way
to
think about this issue of scarcity is to
just look at the price signals because
the price signals are really really
clear signals I want to show you what
those price signals about affordability
look like but I just want to underscore
this point that the growth has continued
I want to home in on about a 40 year
period starting in 1980 and ending right
now and again this is the population of
the world it's increased by almost 75
percent over that 40 year period this is
some of the fastest population growth
that we've ever witnessed in the history
of the world the total GDP the total
economic output of the world has
increased by about two and a half times
over that 40-year period again this is
just by this ban of human history this
is extraordinarily fast growth so we're
building our societies our populations
our economies are growing that has to
put some strain on resources right a lot
of us would expect myself included a lot
of would expect that this crazy
unprecedented growth would cause
resources to become more scarce would
cause them to become less affordable
over time so let's look at that and I
want to cite the work of a couple
scholars who are involved in something
called the Simon abundance project and
they come up the really clever way to
look at this issue of affordability of
resources over time and the way they
approached it was to say ok let's start
with 1980 how much of these different
resources they have a bundle of 50
different commodities or resources and
they asked themselves a really
interesting question they said how much
of each one of these different 50 things
could the world's average worker buy
with one hour of their labor and this is
nice because it gets us out of rich
world versus developing world just like
take all the workers in the world find
that one right there at 50% calculate
what that person's hourly wage was turns
out you have the evidence to do all
these things and then say ok it's that
amount of money how much can they buy
with that hours worth of money in a
bunch of different categories in
categories like food
you know let's say that the world's
average worker could buy one bag of
oranges in 1980 with one hours worth of
work I have no idea if the bag is the
right unit of measure here just humor me
on this
how much plywood could they buy could
they buy one sheet of plywood with an
hour's worth of work could they buy one
pound of copper could they buy one big
lump of coal let's just look at how much
somebody could buy with an hour the
average person in the world with an hour
of their labor in 1980 and then where
things get clever as they say okay let's
do the same calculation for 1981 1982
let's march through the years and look
at what happens to the amount of time
that same average person has to work in
order to buy exactly that same quantity
of oranges plywood copper coal whatever
and the intuition here is that if the
number of minutes they have to work
starts going down that's a really nice
way to say that the resources have
become more affordable if the average
number of minutes they have to work goes
up that means resources are getting less
affordable which is a really good
synonym for they're getting more scarce
out there on the face of the planet so
let's look at what happened over this
about 40-year period here's what's
happened to the bundle of foodstuffs
that includes that bag of oranges it
includes fish meal chicken pork beef you
know stuff that we eat it's gone down
pretty substantially the products that
we take from nature would cotton timber
wolf stuff like that also gone down a
lot materials are a little bit Spiker
spiky er metals and minerals of the rise
of China as the world's factory caused a
bit of a spike in metals prices but they
wind up still at a pretty low place and
even though prices for fuels just
bounced all over the place for lots of
geopolitical reasons the trend there is
also a pretty downward trend if you just
take the straight average of all 50 of
those resources and look at what
happened over time this is what the line
looks like so essentially the bundle
that the world's average person had to
work for an hour to get in 1980
by 2018 they had to work about 20
minutes to get exactly that same bundle
the affordability has increased by about
two-thirds over that space of time this
to me is a very very clear signal that
scarcity is the opposite of what we've
been experiencing over that period even
again as population grew very quickly as
prosperity grew very quickly amazingly
enough we didn't start running out of
the earth we didn't start running out of
these resources by this pretty good
measure they actually became more
abundant more affordable more accessible
to people all over the world the other
thing that I want to talk about in
addition to how affordable resources
were is how did our appetite how did our
raw appetite for resources change like
we've already seen our raw appetite for
more consumption for more prosperity for
more affluence didn't really slow down
at all in the years after Earth Day but
what happened to our appetite for actual
molecules actual resources or materials
how has that changed and the results
here were we're deeply bizarre to me
when I first saw them I want to talk
about it by building up from one
industry and I want to look at
agriculture in America over a period of
a few decades and this is what the total
tonnage of crops produced in America
looks like we are an agricultural
powerhouse one of the biggest in the
world we grow lots and lots of stuff and
if you weighed the total agricultural
output of America year after year the
line would go pretty steadily up that
might not be too surprising where things
get surprising to me is when I start
putting the gray lines on this graph and
I start to look at what's been happening
to total resource use related to
agriculture so this is what's been
happening to total fertilizer use in
America and I want to be clear this is
not fertilizer use per person this is
not fertilizer use per acre this is
total tonnage of fertilizer in America
used to generate that green line that
goes up we used to be increasing our
fertilizer use just about in lockstep
with that green line and it's
been flat for decades the total amount
of water that we need to generate all
that agricultural output has been going
down pretty steadily for decades the
total amount of cropland just the acres
that we need to generate all that output
is on a long slow steady decline in the
country that's a really shallow decline
you might not think it's a big deal it
adds up over time since the early 1980s
we have given an amount of cropland back
to nature in America equal in size to
the state of Washington it's a big chunk
of land we just don't farm it anymore
it's going back to nature gradually if
we blow up if we look more broadly than
just at the agricultural sector and bowl
it up to look at the economy of a whole
we see the pretty same phenomenon taking
place so again here's our line for the
total size of the US economy our total
consumption and the growth in that year
after a year we all know that in
addition to energy economies run on
paperwork so let's look at what's been
happening in total paper consumption in
America again lockstep with the size of
the overall economy and then a plateaued
in the early years of this century and
it's been in freefall for about the past
decade the same thing is true for the
other main product that we get out of
trees different uses of timber are
falling quite quickly and I want to show
you what's been happening to the big
five metals that we use in America
before I do that I want to head off one
objection whenever I show what's been
happening to total metals consumption in
America somebody says oh yeah that's
just because we've outsourced all of our
manufacturing all of our production to
China and we don't make things in
America anymore so of course our
consumption of metals is going to go
down domestically that argument is wrong
just at the start because we have not
stopped making things in America we're
still a manufacturing powerhouse our
manufacturing output goes up just about
every non recession year we have
outsourced some absolutely we still make
things in American we make them more and
more every year now this is what our
total consumption of metals has been
looking like over that
of time and we see the same kind of big
decoupling of the output from all of the
material inputs as we saw earlier our
metals used to be going up just just in
lockstep with the overall size of the
economy and in particular the size of
the manufacturing sector now leveled off
and in most cases actually decreasing
the other really important thing to
notice about this graph is that I tried
to make the line for each metal the same
color as the metal and I really want
credit for that because I think it's
thank you we started off by talking
about energy and that complete one for
one relationship between the size of the
economy and the amount of energy
generated so let's check back in look
what's happened happening since 1970
here's where we worth energy use up
until the first Earth Day here's what's
been happening in the years since we are
decoupling profoundly the growth of our
economy the growth of our society and
our prosperity from the total amount of
joules or BTUs that you need to generate
that economy our economy is about 25
percent bigger than it was at the end of
the Great Recession our energy use is
essentially flat all throughout that
time the added good news here is that
largely because of the fracking
revolution where we're burning less coal
and using more natural gas to generate
electricity
our total greenhouse gas emissions are
actually now trending downward over time
and that red line is really interesting
it comes from a data source that takes
into account the carbon generated by all
the products that we import so this
really is the accurate picture of the
carbon footprint of the American economy
and I think it is past its peak it's
trending down and I will take anyone's
bet that we're not going to hit that
high point ever again or at least for
the next ten years now I want to say
this really clearly this line is not
going down quickly enough I am NOT
encouraging any kind of complacency here
but we have finally d-cup
growing our economy from generating
greenhouse gases in a pretty deep way so
when I think about this problem the
obvious question is what happened we had
this massive reversal in our industrial
age habits between what was happening at
until about the first Earth Day and then
the decade since we've already kind of
eliminated the possibility that we
embraced D growth at a massive scale so
what did change why are these lines now
trending downward over time to get an
answer to this we have to go to the
obvious source which is a RadioShack ad
from 1991 this is actually a true story
there's a retired newsmen in Buffalo
named Steve Sushant and his idea of a
good time is to go around to yard sales
in Buffalo and see if he can find things
that remind him of Buffalo's past get a
sense of his own city's history and he
was at a yard sale he saw a stack of
Buffalo news newspapers from 1991 and
his eyes lit up
bought them took them on paid $4 I think
for them and he's flipping through and
he sees this RadioShack ad from 1991 and
he noticed something fascinating about
that ad he said there are 15 devices
physical devices on this ad 13 of them
have completely vanished from your life
in your world and they've collapsed down
into this tiny little device that you
carry with you all the time
now I don't know about you all I don't
carry a camcorder anymore I don't think
I own one I don't have a police scanner
I don't have a fax machine anymore I
don't have a camera I don't have an
answering machine I don't have a fax I
don't have these things these devices
are not part of my life
but I still communicate I still take
pictures I still consume media I still
compute I do a lot of things I just do
them with this physically very very
small very resource non intensive device
for me this counterpoint is Exhibit A of
the phenomenon that I got so interested
in that I wrote the book about it this
phenomenon of dematerialization by which
we mean
just continuing to grow our economies
our prosperity our ability to consume
while taking fewer materials while using
fewer materials and exhausting less not
less per capita less total of the
Earth's bounty over time the only person
I think that saw this coming was
Buckminster Fuller weirdly enough and in
the 20s he said I think we're gonna turn
the corner he called the process
ephemeralization that's a little too
hard to say so we just say
dematerialization now but once you
become aware of it you start to see it
all over the place it's in obvious ways
in subtle ways in the foreground economy
the background of the economy there was
a really nice story in Bloomberg just a
little while back about the crazy
progress that we're seeing with cars and
particularly car engines in the recent
history of America this is what's been
happening to the average power of the
car engines in America as measured by
how long it takes to go 0 to 70 I think
Bloomberg pointed out that the best
toyota camry fastest toyota camera you
can buy today is almost as fast as the
aston martin that james bond drove
around now you will not be as cool as
James Bond in the camera we can all
agree on that
but you're gonna go almost as fast as he
did while that same phenomenon was
taking place of engines becoming more
powerful they became lighter they became
smaller they became lighter over time
and their fuel efficiency especially
when there are these government mandates
in place their fuel efficiency went up
it's just a win-win-win solution with
the internal combustion engine that
powers big parts of our economy to this
day the last example I want to give
comes from a great story that I heard
from a friend of mine who's had a really
long career of not Stewart in this case
I was having dinner with him early on in
writing the book and I was trying to
explain what I was interested in he said
I've got a great example for you he said
I started my career in 1968 and I went
to work for a conglomerate that owned
the Chicago and Northwest railway and he
said I got put on a team and our
assignment was to figure out where our
boxcars were
in the country I said what he said yet
we had no idea he said the lure in our
industry in the railroad industry in
1968 was that only about 5% of our
inventory of our inventory of boxcars
moved on any given day and it wasn't
that the other 5% 95% needed to rest he
said we didn't know where they were
we had no visibility over them these are
30 ton Assemblies of metal and they were
out running wild on the thousands of
miles of railroad track he said we just
we didn't know he said what we did know
was that if we could take that 5% up to
10% forget it a five percentage point
improvement we would need half as many
of these things so you can imagine what
that would do to your bottom line if you
could just drop your inventory of these
extremely heavy capital intensive assets
if you needed half as many to generate
we would take that deal all day long so
he said our team started we would do
things like hire people called spotters
whose job it was to stand by a railroad
crossing all day watch trains go by and
then Telegraph back to HQ when they saw
one of our own this is actually why lots
of box cars still have those kinds of
numbers on them this is not just to make
hobbyist train spotters lives easier
this is because we needed to know where
they were and visual signals were the
only ones we had so my friend said you
know in the late 1960s we started to
hear about this crazy thing called the
digital computer that might help us with
some of the things we were interested in
so we started to kind of experiment with
these now obviously fast-forward to 2019
every boxcar every one of these huge
things has an rfid tag or three on it
there are trackside sensors all over the
place there are millions of daily EDI
messages sent throughout the industry
and I'm pretty sure that every railroad
in most countries knows where all of its
boxcars are all of the time we're just
out of that 5% 95% business so you blow
that up and used
to think about how much better
visibility we have over the assets that
we possess as companies and how much
better we can use them how utilization
rates go up and again these are all
trends that contribute to the
dematerialization of the economy so when
I think about this problem that we
identified that we're going to run out
of the Earth's bounty I am not worried
about that as I look ahead because of
these trends that we've just been
looking at
I think the one-two punch that we have
developed of computers of these very
powerful digital tools and capitalism
and by that I mean the combination of
companies and private property but
really fundamentally intense competition
and this intense drive to lower cost to
get a little bit ahead of your rivals to
keep winning that battle that is a
really really powerful combination if we
had a bunch of monopolists I would be a
lot less confident about
dematerialization and resource use
monopolist can just pass any increase
cost on to their customer they don't
care companies that are engaged in an
authentic competition they care a great
deal and in particular if somebody comes
along and says hey I can take that five
percent up to ten percent fifty percent
ninety five percent with this thing
called the computer companies will take
that deal all day long so this
combination of intense competition
that's inherent in proper capitalism and
this new toolkit that we have that lets
us essentially find all these
opportunities to use fewer atoms fewer
molecules fewer resources and use more
and more of the digital world of bits
and data man that's a powerful
combination it is letting us live in an
era of affordability and abundance
instead of scarcity and it's letting us
lighten our footprint over time on the
earth I this is the evidence is pretty
clear to me in America unfortunately
other countries haven't kept such
detailed records about their materials
use over time I think dematerialization
is a pretty common phenomenon in the
richest countries in the world I think
it's going to spread pretty quickly as
well and maybe we can talk about that
during the Q&A so I've been cheerleading
pretty hard if you've been listening and
thinking I'm a cheerleader for the
combination of capitalism and technology
you're absolutely right but every decent
economist that I know would say there's
a very important categories of problem
that this combination does not solve is
not set up to solve and really we
shouldn't look here to address it and in
particular this third category of big
problem that we are polluting the world
progressively over time and we are being
really hard on a lot of the animals a
lot of the creatures that we share the
planet with computers in capitalism is
popular as powerful as they are they're
not going to deal with these problems
and these are real problems the year
before Earth Day this is the Koya hoga
River in downtown Cleveland it caught on
fire
this is actually not a picture of the
1969 fire in Cleveland this is a picture
of I think the 1954 fire on the river in
Cleveland apparently by the time 1969
came around the people of Cleveland were
so used to the river catching on fire
that nobody even took a snapshot of it
just part of your day but there are
bodies of water and particularly the
ones that flute that flowed by
manufacturing centers these are terribly
polluted places the air in our skies was
getting worse steadily in the years
leading up to the first Earth Day some
of us in this room as I look around
probably remember when you would get
smog alerts or air alerts on your drive
in to work every day and smog and haze
were a fact of life in most American
cities not to too long ago this is the
passenger pigeon in 1815 the great
naturalist James Audubon was travelling
through America and he saw a flock of
passenger pigeons flying overhead he
said it took three days for the flock to
pass and at times it was so dense that
it blotted out the Sun the last
passenger pigeon died in a zoo in
Cincinnati in 1914 in a century we took
this animal and wiped it off the face of
the earth we almost did the same with a
bunch of other animals and this is just
strikes me it's just this moral just
crime just this huge mistake this is the
biggest animal that's ever lived on the
planet Earth this is the blue whale and
I kind of had this naive idea before I
started working on the book that whales
got in real trouble during the 19th
century we hunted them for their oil and
it was the you know the Moby Dick era of
whaling that was the warm-up act whales
got in really serious trouble during the
20th century when us ingenious human
beings we invented the rocket launched
grenade tipped harpoon and we invented
giant ships that were essentially
carving boards so that you didn't have
to limit yourself to whales that floated
after they were dead the reason the
right whale is called the right whale is
it because it was the right one to hunt
in the 19th century when you needed a
whale that we float after it was killed
humpbacks blue whales lots of other ones
don't in the 20th century that stopped
being a problem we could hunt them very
effectively and we did we drove them to
the brink of extinction if there were
this many blue whales in the world
Southern Oceans in 1900 they're about
this many left by 1973 far as we can
tell they're about 500 individual of
these animals left on the planet in the
early 1970s we hunted them to make
lubricants and margarine we had other
sources to make these materials right
but we went after whales it's just just
I can't wrap my mind around what a
mistake that is so the reason that I'm
intensely grateful to the environmental
movement of the voices of Earth Day is
that they said stop you cannot keep
doing this you can't keep polluting our
skies in our water you cannot keep
driving more and more animals to the
brink of extinction or beyond we demand
action and they got it and they got it
from governments that were responsive to
the will of their people that listened
to evidence that listened expert opinion
don't you get kind of nostalgic for
those days
but we put in place these these limits
on what you could do we put animals
outside the mark you just can't hunt
them we set up hunting seasons we set up
marine parks and we came up these really
clever mechanisms to drive down
pollution and what's been happening in
the years since since these landmark
pieces of legislation were passed the
trends are absolutely fantastic the
Cuyahoga is now a trout fishing stream
again not too far outside of Cleveland
here is where we left atmospheric
pollution leading up to Earth Day in
1970 here's what's been happening since
we just we don't worry about unhealthy
air we should pollution is still too
high in a lot of places we don't get
smog alerts anymore our particulate air
pollution levels are less than a tenth
of what they were at the time of Earth
Day and if we check in with our I'm
sorry if we think about global warming
which we can all agree is a dire problem
and a problem that's getting worse the
instant I start thinking about it as a
type of pollution as pollution caused by
greenhouse gases the problem becomes
clearer to me and I say this I don't say
this to minimize the problem or
trivialize the problem at all all I'm
trying to do is categorize the problem
properly because once you think about
greenhouse gases as pollution then you
understand the toolkit for addressing
them and in particular the toolkit that
works really well for other kinds of
atmospheric pollution is put a price on
the pollution make it a thing that
businesses have to spend on like they
spend for every other material out there
and then watch them try not to spend
money on it watch them flee from that
cost this is what drove down our air
pollution levels so much I imagine a lot
of us in this room have at least two
friends who are economists
if you have at least two economist
friends you realize that economists
agree on nothing and your two friends or
any number will just fight endlessly
about any topic in economics I say this
to bring up the fact that economists are
not fighting about the most powerful
tool to address global warming to
address greenhouse gas pollution this is
an open letter arguing for a carbon tax
and in particular a carbon tax where the
government doesn't keep the money it
just sends it right back out to the
citizens of the country called a carbon
dividend this letter was originally
signed by a few dozen economists by now
the open letter has been signed by more
than 3,500 prominent economists this has
never happened before in the history of
the discipline they would not sign a
letter about the Sun rising in the east
but the the level of unanimity hear
about the the most powerful policy tool
that we have to combat global warming is
just incredibly clear it's very
frustrating that we're not doing this
we're not even taking it very seriously
here's where we left our whales in the
early 1970s that's where the blue whales
were here's where they are now they're
not all the way back and they might
never get back to those previous levels
but one phrase that I learned from
Stewart the last time he and I were
together is one that I just carry around
with me all the time
Stewart didn't invent us but he said it
and I thought it was fantastic its
nature bats last and if you carry that
idea around you just come to the
conclusion that look we make mistakes
and we shouldn't make them but if we can
get out of the way if we can leave if we
can leave the field let the oceans
repopulate don't hunt there anymore stop
farming that land and let it go back to
nature nature can rejuvenates
astonishingly resilient nature actually
bats last so these are the problems that
we've identified the solution here is
not computers in capitalism the solution
here for the problems of pollution and
species loss is an aware public and a
government that responds to its public
to good evidence through expert opinion
and if you put all four of these things
together in the book I call these the
four horsemen of the
as a bit of a counterpart to some of the
apocalyptic thinking that's going on
these days and when all of these four
horsemen ride together I get really
confident that the state of the world
and the human condition are going to
improve simultaneously I started with a
litany of woes let me end with a litany
of some of the really fantastic things
that are going on and I luckily I didn't
have to dig too hard for these either
this is what's been happening to the
number of people living in extreme
poverty around the planet again this is
not a percentage this is the number of
people living in a consistent measure of
deep poverty that number is lower than
it was 200 years ago in 1820 a lot of
people say this is a China phenomenon it
absolutely is
it's not exclusively a China phenomenon
every region of the world is lifting its
people out of the deepest poverty every
region in the world is making more and
more calories available to its people
that I've got a thin line drawn there at
2,500 calories that's an important
benchmark because it's about what an
active adult male needs to maintain his
body weight as recently as 1980 the
world's average person did not have
access to 2,500 calories a day every
region in the world
is providing its people with that much
on average every part of the world is
enrolling more kids in school lifespans
are increasing in every region of the
world the countries of southern Africa
are finally past the terrifying AIDS
crisis and their average lifespan is
increasing we talk about inequality a
great deal for reasons that are obvious
and we need to have this conversation I
just want to point out there are some
aspects of inequality that are
decreasing very quickly important
aspects of inequality maternal and child
mortality those inequalities are
decreasing I am NOT saying for a second
that they're low enough that this
inequality is vanished it hasn't we have
a lot of work ahead of us but I love
this phrase that I've heard from hands
Rosling this is a bad old world and it's
getting better so I want to end with an
image that is just unapologetically
plucking at your
heartstrings but it's not Photoshop can
we solve our big problems and I'll
actually refine that question a little
bit can we resolve our big problems
while continuing our growth our mania
for growth yeah we absolutely can I
think the evidence is overwhelming on
this we can absolutely do it here's the
final image I want to share with you
again I'm not making this up the whales
are back off the coast of New York City
how's that for a good one to end on
thank you
I should point out Andy's book is got
all these graphs and a lot of economics
and also a lot of stories like the right
whale story that I had never heard
before
yeah I mean I was part of the save the
whales movement we get a fair amount of
whales I should point out actually that
the California blue whale is back to the
original level is that right for we
started whaling not the the southern
Atlantic one I guess you were talking
about but the local ones are and that
you would call it the right whale
because it was the one that would float
and I could see a with it not be good
harpoon the guy I got a lot of blubber
oops
yeah what's have oil sink on New Year's
gotta be one of those things
um let's talk about these bets you
didn't make a part of the talk then we
got a slide let's look at the slide do
we see I wish it here in 2029 these all
10-year bets the US will consume less
total energy than it did does now in
2019 will produce less total co2
emissions the next one is less tonnage
of rare earth elements this sounds like
Julian Simon betting Paul Ehrlich and
winning there is a little shout out
there yeah so sort of summarize what are
these things all basically sort of just
massive output and prices and things
like that or what their combination of
these two things that I highlighted in
response to the second problem we're
using up all the world's bounty right
right I don't think we are I and I think
the evidence for that is that things are
getting more affordable mm-hmm and the
US economy is dematerializing we're
using less stuff year after year so
these bets are a combination of those
two ideas and my prediction that they're
going to continue and the reason I think
that you and your colleagues were so
smart to create the long bets
organization is as the Alex Tabarrok was
a pretty
economists put it bets are a tax on
[ __ ]
and now he's really honest I am tired of
some of the Malthusian overly gluey
[ __ ] that I hear about everything
going to hell in a handcart
and I'm not saying everything is fine
these things are going to get better
instead of worse in the future and I
will put money behind that so in a sense
what we're trying to do with long breath
says make predictions accountable and
falsifiable so it's often the case you
gotta get really specific about how
you're gonna measure and the deal is
that when the time is up long and out
promises that we will adjudicate with a
panel of experts if needed as to who won
the bet and that unfortunately money
doesn't change hands between the betters
at that point because it's you're not
allowed to bet the accept on poker in
Nevada in the United States it's illegal
so what you do is if you win you've got
now we get the money you put in with the
money of the other guy put in and the
interest is growing in the ten years or
whatever since that long that's a fair
amount of interest and then that goes to
the charity that you would love to see
get a bunch of money and notoriety so
that's the deal yep you're putting up a
hundred thousand dollars well only if
the other side puts up that much money
which is not happening yet but if I find
if I look it is unethical to let suckers
keep their money I deeply believe that
and if there are that many suckers
gloomy pessimistic suckers ah fine bring
it on and then charities ten years from
now will have 200k plus interest let's
do it so if other and other people can
respond to your best they can put up
bets that you might join on some of
these subjects that sounds like the hard
part which you pointed out is making
them falsifiable and assessable that's
why this language is kind of specific
and nerdy because we have to have as you
know we have to have ways for your
experts to benchmark who won these
things a lot of these things they get to
be always served short versions of the
notion and the thing I heard about a lot
in the 70s 80s and 90s was Peak Oil yeah
and there were books about how
once we had peak oil we're gonna hit it
the king Hubbert and run out of oil in
the ground and then there would be this
economic collapse we're not ready for
that and are part of the environmental
movement was loving the idea of
everything coming to a screeching halt
kind of bought into that and then I got
to working for Royal Dutch Shell for a
while and what I learned from inside
that world is there's a whole lot of
undiscovered oil and oil that they were
not talking about a whole lot of
discovered oil that they were obviously
keeping quiet not to let the competition
know there was no prospect of peak oil
and nobody ever said peak coal because
you know it's major part of the surface
of the earth but that peak oil concept
which was in a sense of economic concept
but it was just it was a fantasy it was
a story that was clarity seemed well so
obvious the Population Bomb had a
similar quality we tell these stories
that what happens what invites that
swearing allegiance to a story that
leaks its truth over time it doesn't
leak allegiance of the people who
believe what's going on with that I wish
you had an answer for that one I thought
I'd come to you with that question
because I don't quite get it there the
reluctance of people to honestly try to
honestly look at evidence and to abandon
their priors is just one of the most
enduring aspects of the human condition
I think and people just keep doubling
down on things that I think have been
pretty thoroughly debunked the the pros
don't so like you probably know inside
the oil and gas industry people still
talk about peak oil but they mean peak
demand right not peak supply which has
happened in Europe that peak demand for
a lot of material things apparently in
it yeah and I think the insiders think
every year they think that peak oil
demand globally is going to come a
little bit sooner but we you know we
still walk around I grabbed headlines
very easily about the looming resource
crisis though the looming affordability
crisis I just think it's insane Joshua
asked is there a maximum human carrying
capacity or yes but I don't know what it
is nobody knows what it is and all of
our previous limits all of our previous
estimates of what that capacity is have
been meaningless have been just
unbelievably wrong and bad so I've come
out in favor of nuclear power as have
you thank you I learned from the best
that hasn't changed massive minds yet
but maybe it will in light of climate
change but I have heard from George
Dyson who thinks kind of life his father
Freeman Dyson and Planetary
multiplanetary terms his worry is that
if we get a lot of cheap clean safe
nuclear or move on to fission or fusion
and you know even more that that
squander ibly cheap clean energy would
lead humanity into an excess behavior
but excess you in the common sense of
that what ok numbers people population
is an issue at that scale the reason
that comfort that countries go through
the demographic transition and have
fewer kids is not because they become
2-foot poor to afford them it's because
they become so rich they don't need as
many farmhands out there the affluence
is what causes family size to go down we
observe this over and over so if
suddenly a household line item goes to
zero energy goes to zero mm-hmm we're
going to start having eight kids just
it's it flies in the face of all of this
evidence in all this history I just I
don't get it
okay carbon taxes max Nova asked you
have to kite mmm pricing carbon but
doesn't figuring out the price required
predicting costs for in the futures and
long term economic forecasting
impossible so there's a carbon tax gonna
you know what keeps a carbon tax
rationale in a sense yeah it's a good
question because our ability to forecast
anything long-term especially economic
indicators is just laughably bad yep
still do it a bunch that doesn't mean
that we can't make a decent estimate
using short term estimate and calibrate
that carbon tax over time it's exactly
what we did with cap and trade programs
will suffer that sulfur dioxide
pollution and lots happened trade
certain market partly decides that or
what yeah the government sets the cap
and then companies and they it lowers
the cap year after year so we've got to
figure out the rate of lowering we've
got to figure out who's got the right to
who is the initial pollution allowance
under cap'n tree these are really
complicated things but they're not
impossible and the reason you hire a
team of good economists to help you
think through this is because they can
do a lot better than just blind chance
and figuring out what the right level of
a carbon dividend is or what the right
structure for a trade for a market to
trade these things is they gave the
Nobel Prize last year in economics to
William Nordhaus
in large part for his work on the carbon
dividend it's a hard problem it's not
impossible in here and so the price of
it
what should be the tax on a tonne of
coal so yeah it's you do it are you
probably a number in your mind I don't
know what the what Nordhaus says the
optimal initial tax is and you don't tax
the coal you tax the carbon generated by
burning the call you tax the pollution
itself and then what economists say I
wholeheartedly agree with is once you
get that structure basically right get
the hell out of the way and let the
market figure out how to reduce those
costs we see how well that works with
other kinds of resources if you make
pollution a costly thing businesses will
innovate like crazy to bring that cost
down the mistake that I keep making even
though this is what I'm supposed to do
for a living I keep under estimating
human ingenuity and inventiveness it's
really easy to do and I think if we
actually put a real carbon tax in place
we would see the situation change more
quickly than we're anticipating okay so
Jenn Harris asks why our us productivity
statistics flat since 2000 and I see
we're just about out of time Thanks
it's a really deep mystery and we I
don't think we have great answers for it
and in a sense it conflicts this amazing
you know technology-driven story that
I'm telling if we were living in this
amazing era of tech progress the first
place that economists would go look for
evidence of that is the productivity
statistics and like you point out
they've been super underwhelming for
over a decade I think the best answer to
that comes from no surprise Erik
Brynjolfsson my co-author and colleague
on a bunch of things and he says the the
time lag between the appearance of a
really powerful new technology toolkit
and the appearance of the effects in the
productivity statistics that eight years
it can actually be decades so I think
for example about artificial
intelligence and machine learning which
are clearly going to transform the
economy and clearly have not done so yet
they've changed a few industries they
make my phone easier to use my you know
I can sort my pictures more easily
hasn't transformed healthcare yet but
it's going to so I think we're gonna
look back in you know 2040 2050 and
laugh at our concerns about the
productivity slowdown if it transforms
healthcare how does that affect
productivity and GDP and things like
that well I use healthcare as an example
because it will it'll transform
manufacturing it'll transform logistics
it'll transform Commerce and those are
the areas where we'll see the biggest
bang for the buck in the productivity
statistics but one thing I'm trying to
point out in more from less is that the
material productivity the amount of GDP
per molecule and the economy has been
skyrocketing in a way that we've never
seen before
so you did this earlier book I'm the
second Machine Age when did you do that
2014 it came out okay I was few years
ago and doing the research for this book
what was surprising or news to you since
you did the work on second Machine Age
when when Eric and I wrote second
Machine Age I had no idea of this
phenomenon of dematerialization I just
didn't know that we were in America
using in aggregate fewer resources and I
my intuition would would have been
exactly the opposite you know like I was
trying to show us some of those quotes
as economies grow they consume more
stuff
duh I read this wonderful essay by a guy
you might know named Jesse oz Abell good
friend yeah and just a wonderful thinker
and he wrote this essay there remember
it vividly the title was the return of
nature how technology liberates the
environment mm-hmm you gotta click on
that headline right right so I read it
and he's talking about this thing called
demon transition like he's he's wrong
about he's missing something that not
how growth works it's not no economy's
work but he's a very careful scholar he
listed all of his sources so I went
there and downloaded data I'm banging on
I'm like holy cow he's right and if
anything I think he's low balling this
phenomenon so there's a book down there
so I think he was saying the US was at
peak farmland in the world maybe if
farmland are almost there yeah it's like
Hans Rosling saying we repeat children
yeah in terms of population others talk
about peep peak timber oh it's less and
less stuff going into paper so which I
guess is part of your the rich world has
a story rich world is reforesting quite
quickly not yet in the in some of the
lower income countries but they'll turn
the corner - and one thing I said in the
book which gets reinforced by all this
great satellite data that we have the
earth is now getting greener year after
year not browner and that's great news
for a lot of reasons again it ain't
enough we need to do more but let's
celebrate the fact that we're regrading
the earth finally um Ryan Phelan asks
what about water it's a natural resource
how does that relate to population
growth have you tracked down the water
use at all I guess you did with
agriculture with that what in America
it's pretty clear and another stat that
I didn't put in the book is that Los
Angeles today uses as much water in
total as it did I think 30 or 40 years
ago mm-hmm now it's a much bigger city
it's got a bigger economy that water use
has flatlined the problem with water is
like the problem with a lot of other
resources sand is another one that very
often they don't have a price you can
just go take as much of it as you want
and when that's the case you see all
kinds of really harmful behavior we just
deplete that stuff it's just an example
of the tragedy of the comments but
computer-chip quality sand is I think
scarce resource right it has spiked and
there was this great story in Wired a
couple years
ago about these guys who worked I think
it was from Motorola and they would take
big chunks of super high-quality silicon
and home in their lunch boxes and then
sell it on the black market and a they
got busted and B that would not be a
productive thing for them to do anymore
because the price is created for that
kind of silicon because what happens is
somebody spins up another factory and
generates all the silicon that you want
a silicon that you want we're not
running out of sand in the world that is
not a thing that's happening Peaks and
yeah Alexandra Rosa says how do you
think eventual population decrease will
affect all these economies in quality of
life and so we've got some examples
already with Japan and Russia are losing
population absolutely and China will
start pretty quickly they have a
demographic problem that that's gonna be
a different winner here's Japan big
question the nations now is do they get
rich before they get old yeah and Japan
got rich before it got old Russia and
not so much on some people are saying
Japan is like whole nations are just
retired yeah very happy retirement right
stable calm Society can they replace the
absence of a young working population
with robots or does it matter or obvious
at work I think the main reason that
population declines matter and
especially working age population
declines is that the way we've set up
our retirement systems throughout the
world is that current workers pay for
current retirees right and we might need
to reconfigure that as the balance
between retirees and workers changes
like it's going to right the good news
is that we will be wealthy enough to
deal with that problem if we are
thoughtful about it the economic growth
makes societies more abundant more
affluent gives us more money to spread
around we can solve the it's called the
dependency ratio we can solve that
problem I don't pretend it's easy and we
will need a lot more robots but we're
going to get a lot more robots so I'm
worried about the payment system for
retire
around the world I'm not worried that
our aggregate output is gonna crater
because there aren't enough workers
anymore that just seems a little silly
to me uh okay what about China which is
facing what they call population
precipice partly because the one-child
policy probably just cause on growing
affluence not nearly as far as Japan say
yeah all but moving fast but a real
cliff more of a cliff than maybe any
society we've ever seen it just happens
to be the largest and you know in many
ways most significant one in the world
what happens in China was the population
I don't know
turn around III really don't know and I
would rather have our problems than
China's problems as I tried to take a
long view here in particular the things
that I see she doing are more central
planning moral fashion command and
control of a very large economy and Wow
is that a recipe for economic disaster
somewhere down the road so say a little
bit about your formula of the sort of
active citizenry and the responsive
government uh-huh what are the shining
examples of that going well or the not
so shining examples of getting trapped
of it not being able to go well and I'll
stick to domestic examples just because
I know it best there I am incredibly
nostalgic for the Montreal protocols
about CFCs right because a couple guys
published a paper it was either science
or nature they published one paper where
they said hey they're these things
called CFCs and they they might be
contributing to a depletion of this
thing called the ozone layer the science
wasn't even settled yet and of course
all the CFC producing industry said well
the science isn't settled we gotta wait
and see let's not be hasty but we listen
to that research we realized there was a
problem and not just in this country but
around the world we came together to put
a very effective limit and then a ban in
place on those chemicals we were helped
because at some point somebody kind of
walked up to DuPont and said hey the
chemicals you're making now are off
patent mmm-hmm the next generation you
can make a lot of money off of and then
industry got on the right side of that
problem pretty quickly I'm really
nostalgic for that the greenhouse gas
problem is so much
harder because there's no equivalent of
a chemical that's off patent versus on
patent companies are just gonna see
their cost structure increase and it's
not limited to a few companies a few
industries it's just generated by human
activity so it's a tougher problem to
solve
politically conceptually it's the same
kind of thing so I get really nostalgic
for the days of the Montreal Protocol
and are listening to the experts on this
one I get really really concerned about
the current administration's attempts to
rollback our current pollution standards
and I did you see this story in The
Times just a few days ago the air
pollution deaths have increased since
2016 and are probably responsible for
about 10,000 additional early deaths
from air pollution in America since 2016
as far as we can tell that's about twice
as many people has died from early
deaths from the Chernobyl disaster it's
a terrible problem or going in the wrong
direction okay so one all is over
blazing that thinking about the future
based on sort of current events but
current events in the u.s. politically
in UK politically in various places or
autocracies and populist autocracies are
coming on strong massive crowds in the
streets protesting about significant
things where it's going on year after
year more and more are is there some
kind of political ear responsiveness of
becoming hip on what's going on here I I
don't know I spend a chapter of the book
scratching my head about that ha because
it thanks a lot I'm sorry but nobody say
it's a real phenomenon yeah it's not
confined to one country it's not
confined to countries that have too many
immigrants or going through a bad
recession it's a really broad-based
phenomenon and it's scary as hell that
chapter opens with a quote from Jim
mattis and a reporter a couple years ago
asked Madison was still the SEC deaf at
the time he said what are you most
worried about and Madison's answer had
nothing to do with China Russia North
Korea Isis al-qaeda whatever he said a
lack of friendliness back home
he said we have just just we feel so
isolated we feel like we're just
at each other and was so angry all the
time and I think a sociologist would say
he's describing a decline in social
capital he's describing a decline in
trust in institutions he's describing it
just a willingness to even try to come
together and solve big problems I think
he's right I think all those things are
going on and in the face of these
problems that we still have it's scary
as hell thank thank you all for coming
out
well it's but it's hard it's interesting
how a kind of a mmm good news book like
yours we can do more from less we are
doing ever more from ever less it's
basically your statement oh look these
strands are in place and there's their
structural so they're going to keep
getting back
how does book like that play into a set
of populist --is going through the kind
of thing we just described we have to
continue to think that we can persuade
people with logic and evidence based
arguments okay if I didn't wake up every
day and believe there was some chance
that we could do that I just stay in bed
depressed as hell all day and it's it's
easy to lose that faith right now
because a lot of the dominant rhetoric
that we hear is untethered from reality
and evidence and we've got a crop of
brilliant populist and demagogues these
days who are winning the rhetorical
battles and I think that means that our
side let's call them let's call
ourselves a reality based community
mm-hm
oh yeah we get together in the bars and
just talk facts no but no baby nothing
that won't work right that won't work
another word of the mantra is that I can
carry around this one I didn't learn
from you but another one of the mantras
I carry around is a sad one it says you
will never displace a feeling with a
fact so oh that's tough right so how do
you try how do you try to start meeting
somebody halfway who's got this very
different worldview and in in the face
of all these forces of polarization how
do you start and I think we have some
good ideas about how to do that one
thing I say in the book is there are
very few people who are actually
indifferent to environmental degradation
or human suffering like you got to be
pretty far out for that does it matter
to you so if you can start with some
common ground and say look I'm pretty
sure you don't want to see the Bison go
extinct can we start there okay I'm
pretty sure you don't want to go back to
smog-filled skies can we start there and
then just try to build up a conversation
it's look well not okay it's a Loeb life
I grant you that that story I know a bit
which is the Bison or saved by the
pigeons the passenger pigeons went
extinct nobody believed that their
continentally abundant population island
populations quit went extinct all the
time everybody knew that yep Jefferson
didn't even know that the extinction was
a possibility Wow it's that recent
discovery and then the passenger pigeon
went extinct everybody in the u.s. knew
about passenger pigeons because they
were this phenomenon yeah and then
they're gone and then they're down to
zero at which point people like Theodore
Roosevelt said the Bison have been you
know I went hunting for bison I couldn't
find one all day actually all months and
and then he started and some other
people at the various museums
Smithsonian and so on turned that around
and the Bison are on the way back what
about and what's my point the point is
it got me to stall while you know you
know what is the equivalent in terms of
climate in terms of political
responsiveness of government and of the
they engaged populace what is the
equivalent of losing the passenger
pigeon in relation to climate so right
now everybody's trying to put hurricanes
and forest fires as an indicator at
least in a consequence to some degree of
climate change sea level rise and you
know they get the document we had Jeff
Goodell here talking about daylight
sunlight floods in Florida and so on and
what he was continuing to see is the
prices of property that were getting
flooded in the sun-god bubbling down yet
that was actually when I started to get
bleak about all this because you would
expect the people in frontlines of
things actually caused by climate change
like sunlight flooding and king tides
that they would be going oh well even
though I'm in Florida even though we
have you know Republican perspective on
all this this is too real to not start
admitting what's happening but there is
some turnaround so I guess I'm gonna be
looking for sooner than later please
some sense that the passenger pigeons
are going extinct and if we want to save
the bison we've got to do something that
is much more actually than we have does
that make it it makes a ton of sense and
I don't think there'll be one
precipitating event like the extinction
of the passenger that's the problem
yeah I agree but I but I do think that
most people outside of our elected
officials are aware of climate change
believe it and believe it's bad and that
awareness is getting better over time
how do we harness that and turn that
into collective action and why has that
not happened yet I don't know but but
the we're not we're not ignorant of the
problem or unconcerned about it I too
many
are just convinced a ball that the cost
the cost is going to be too high or that
interesting so denial okay we're going
through denial it sounds like I think
Nile is the easiest thing to do with the
threats at large yeah you're gonna dine
or not yep or you just swing all the way
other into fatalism and like we're
screwed and there's nothing I can do
about it which is equally unhelpful yeah
well at least let's get the bargaining
for Tracy yeah yeah but my point is and
what the thing I try to say in the book
is let's elect people who will put in
place the toolkit that is proven to work
the thing that we know will work a
carbon dividend properly constructed
will work do you like the dividend we
like the money going straight remember
when this was first proposed few years
ago people say oh yeah right you just
want the money to go right back to the
everybody yeah say why because it's
easier sell get a check from the
government sounds pretty good right a
lot of people don't trust the government
to spend their money pretty well and you
do want to help out the people whose
household budgets are going to be
inflated because of the price on carbon
but that's a legitimate thing that will
happen and then in terms of making more
equality is every individual in the
nation that does this get the same
amount of money and I and I talked about
this and so that's progressive yeah this
degree where they start to disagree is
on exactly that question should it be
calibrated based on income or should
rich people and poor people get the same
size carbon dividend and that's where
the economic arguments break out I think
that's the second-order question the
first one is just get it in place and
get the tax high enough that companies
will actually change their behavior so
there's five thousand economists that
like the carbon tax do they also like
that give it in the economist statement
says give the same check to everybody
Wow yeah that's interesting
well here's Liz rollator with a question
dear to my heart she's saying we've
decoupled and we got dematerialization
going along on manufacturing and so on
maintenance is the cost of maintenance
all these things going down or up or
you're keeping track that's a great
question I did not look at that for the
book um my guess is that our ability to
predict when complicated expensive
pieces of machinery are about to break
that that predictability is going up
pretty quickly right so we'll be doing
better preventative maintenance on a lot
of these expensive things now it is true
they're free that's a very subtle piece
which is I'm discovering in my own
research actually the case especially in
manufacturing and aircraft and things
like that where they're able to detect
not deterioration of the behavior of the
machine yet but they can detect that
there are signals that the is about to
start losing efficiency and an airline
really doesn't want to take that really
expensive asset out of service for any
length of time they'd rather do a
scheduled maintenance on it so it's like
boxcars than that yeah I think that's a
phenomena it is true though that a lot
of the appliances that we buy we don't
maintain because they don't last for 30
years anymore they're designed for a
shorter life and I hear people say how
terrible that is do you know how
energy-efficient that 30-year old
washing machine is these are motor used
a ton more energy it used a ton more
water per load and that things kind of
an environmental nightmare we should get
rid of it and the refrigerators when you
open the door all the cold air for long
yeah well I it is the case people who
are getting a totally electric cars are
shocked at their repair bills which
basically disappear because there's no
fluids except the windshield washer
fluid yeah and the number of moving
parts is a very small fraction of
practice and so it has changed the
economics of car dealerships because
particle keeps car dealerships going is
there repairing the cars that they sell
this doesn't work for Tesla yeah yeah
and that's part of why the whole
dealership thing is completely different
for these electric cars and I can tell
you I've got one and it's in the shop
thing just goes away and in general you
know incumbent
incumbents resist big change that's just
that's how incumbents behave the status
quo is generally good to them they want
to perpetuate it so the forces of
disruption have an uphill battle but you
like capitalism Kisuke exact because it
rewards disruption right we need more of
that not less you get pushback on what
parts of your formula here mostly all of
them really fill the fill in the blank
because they're good news or because
people disapprove of this that or the
other thing I've had some really good
pushback on specific claims that I've
made and some evidence that I drew on
some some really helpful discussions
have happened but in general I think
there is a law of conservation of
pessimism out there in the universe
yeah there's also speaking idea either a
physicist or an economist here
conservation pessimism pessimism yeah if
you want to if you want to feel bad
about the world then you're gonna resist
any attempt to say actually you know
infant child mortality is decreasing and
then they argue with you and thanks to
this amazing website we spend time on
our world and data this is this is the
nerds favorite websites an amazing
resource and you can just point anybody
and there's rarely systematic really
good data on declines in mortality for
example let me find something else to
get upset about and then I want to say
this very carefully that the law of
conservation of pessimism tends to have
its last Battlement on climate change
hmm and and I've heard people say these
things that you're saying or maybe
they're kind of interesting yay you know
yay dematerialization nothing else
matters except climate change and we are
still doomed because of global warming
yeah and that's where that's what this
kind of pessimistic fatalistic argument
kicks in and at some point you just have
to kind of stop you so look if you want
to walk around pessimistic like I I
can't stop you all I have all I have
again is logic and evidence if that
doesn't work go be unhappy well I guess
the question there is does does the
presence of climate change as an issue
and the presence of climate change as
being impactful on for example
developing nations in the global south
and so on
does it affect the trend lines the
mechanics of the trend lines that you're
reporting on it it probably will
I think the magnitude of those impacts
is extremely unclear I am not trying to
be I'm not a lukewarm ER I'm not trying
to present myself that way those
dynamics are extremely unclear and I
just saw today as I was getting ready
for this talk that is if the IPCC has
lowered some of its estimates because
renewables are getting so much cheaper
so quickly that they actually think the
world's energy trajectory is now going
to look different than their previous
estimate and that brings down the
overall amount of warming that they're
experiencing I don't want to quote this
don't this is not chapter and verse but
I just saw that today we're gonna get
we're gonna continue to get surprised by
human ingenuity and most of that
ingenuity is going to go in helpful
directions so for example do I think as
bad as global warming is it will you
know we will no longer be able to feed
ourselves in 2100 I absolutely do not
believe that not for a second
there'll be challenges we're good at
meeting challenges fair enough okay
coming up to the end here this is this
book grew out of the last book it sounds
like what's gonna grow out of this book
do you have another domain you're
starting to look into or think about or
you're just living this one down
it's like asking somebody who just left
the battlefield what War II was
interested in fighting next I'm sorry
this is a little more like football than
world war as a coach and player you're
gonna probably view more books you've
been rewarded for doing some good ones
and I hope we will reward you for this
one are there domains you really wanted
to explore at the book level coming up
yeah the next thing that I'm fascinated
in tackling comes from a great quote
from Leo Wilson there's the astonishing
ant scientist who looked around at us at
this species where he had two great
quotes one was he said about communism
great idea wrong species the other great
quote he said was he looked around at us
and he said we humans are super
interesting we have Paleolithic Minds
medieval institutions and godlike
technologies that's exactly right
and he was talking about Star Wars was
he talk about Star Wars
yeah the movie specifically not ha I
didn't know that Peter just asked Stuart
any of these questions but if that's
true and I think there's a huge amount
of insight there we can't change our
minds overnight we have just wired that
way our technologies are amazing we have
to work on our institutions we have to
get them out of the medieval era the the
the industrial era and redesign them to
be a pro proof of this world that we
live in now taking into account how
weird our brains actually are and this
astonishing toolkit that we have so
reformulating that was a really fun
thing to think about okay so you're an
economist mainly yes I'm economist
adjacent promised that me I don't know I
I don't have an economics degree but I
hang out with economists all the time
okay what do you have a degree in it if
anything
I'm an MIT engineer by tree of course
that explains everything I hope you mean
that as a compliment I do okay good
means you try to solve problems and
you're probably good at it so do you
want to take on the design and improve
in an institution yeah so we're talking
about more specifically organizations
right but I think organizations were
designed for a world where information
was scarce and where people were
rational one of those things is not true
anymore the other one never ever was
right let's double down on that
when you look around when I when I come
out to to California and I talked to my
friends who are just reinventing all
kinds of stuff and launching these great
companies what I find fascinating is
they're doing some things really
differently then Industrial Age
companies are doing and I think there's
a reason for that I think they have
internalized this insight from Wilson
and they're trying to get around the
fact that that we're weird right and we
have this constellation of biases and
things going on and that we still have
to get work done out there and the thing
called the company is the vehicle to do
that so they're kind of reinventing it
to be more accurate about the way we
work and and the technologies that we
have access to great so the
institution's you want to change
companies nonprofits government
apparatus what else I'm a business
school guy I'll start with companies
they're an important set of
organizations why you squinting who's
gonna do government who's gonna do
government you know folk like Jen pahlka
are gonna do government folk like Tim
O'Reilly are gonna do governor we have
people here working on it and Jim is
coming into generating outstanding I
like the idea of you taking on
institutions and we can't wait to have
you back thank you
[Applause]
[Music]